un día internacional para la
erradicación de la pobreza con cifras
rojas por primera vez en más de 21 años
la pobreza extrema creció en el mundo
según las naciones unidas la pandemia
mundial de kobe 19 empeoró una situación
ya difícil para los países en desarrollo
y profundizó la brecha entre ricos y
pobres mientras que las fortunas de los
multimillonarios aumentaron en más de
3.9 billones de dólares en 2020 el
número de personas que viven en la
pobreza extrema también creció de 119 a
224 millones de personas
la solidaridad está ausente en la acción
y el sentimiento de injusticia se
extiende creando un caldo de cultivo
para la violencia y los conflictos las
personas que viven en estados frágiles y
afectados por conflictos son las que más
sufren debemos cumplir los compromisos
que hemos asumido para cambiar el ruido
night to change course se suman a los
conflictos armados las dificultades para
encontrar trabajo la inseguridad la
escases de alimentos y los estudios
apuntan a que los países políticamente
inestables frente a un más pobreza
organizaciones y asociaciones que luchan
por los derechos humanos pero también
personalidades como el papá
multiplicaron las alertas este año
[Música]
- armas y más alimentos menos hipocresía
y más transparencia
más vacunas distribuidas equitativamente
y menos armas comercializadas
indiscriminadamente esprode educadamente
la pobreza también empuja a las olas
migratorias y factores como el cambio
climático alimentan el círculo vicioso
de la precariedad las naciones unidas-
llaman ahora a la comunidad
internacional a actuar urgentemente para
limitar los daños